hi welcome to my talk my name is Alber r
i Am A freelancer and A content creator
you may have seen some of my content on
YouTube or Twitter on my main job I am a
math PhD student focusing on probability
Theory but I assure you that today we
are definitely not talking about
mathematics today I want to show you how
to combine HTML and CSS with popular art
tools that you may already use to create
even more beautiful outputs than we
already have with the tools we want so
you may be wondering why is a
mathematician talking about things like
making more beautiful designs making
better tables with GT having a nicer
plot um talking about things like design
so let me tell you how I ended up here
and how the idea for this talk came to
be as a PhD student I also have to teach
and at some point I add that time I felt
like I was getting stuck with the r
course and not with the math course so
um I was sort of getting stuck with
having to teach r i ass you now I would
be very glad about this but at that time
I felt like I was kind of getting the
short end of the
stick but I decided to make the best out
of it so I uh decided to read R for data
science which I am sure all of you have
read and I just learned a lot from it
and one of the things that I found very
striking was that it starts out with
data visualization the very first
chapter teaches you GG plot and to me it
was fascinating how just the very basic
GG plot call that you learn like in the
first page of that chapter was already
creating a plot that was much nicer than
what I could have possibly created at
that time so we will see in this talk
that this is a recurring theme we have
very great tools that can help you to
create very nice outputs all from within
a couple of lines
okay so this is how I started ending up
with data visualization I wanted to
learn more and I kind of went down a
rabbit hole learn more about it and once
you start learning about data Vis you
see other people's work as well and here
I've brought a data Vis from John burn
Murdoch who's creating visualizations
from the financial times and if you
don't know his work you should
definitely check it out he creates
beautiful plots and what I found most
interesting about this particular chart
is that instead of using a legend like a
typical Legend on the right hand side of
the plot to indicate which color means
what instead it highlights single words
and colorizes them for example in a
title you can see that the word British
cities is colored in red and to indicate
that the red dots mean British cities so
I thought well can I do this in ggplot
to and so I set out and tried to create
a scatter plot first using the very
famous Palmer penguins and this is like
a very nice plot that I created with
ggplot it's a decent plot ggplot is a
very fancy tool to make these kind of
things but this was not what I set out
to do I wanted to have the colors not on
the right hand side but in the title so
the question is can we do this with NG
plot and the answer is yeah we can
actually do that but we have to invoke
an extra package that's called GG text
so at this point you are asking probably
okay what's the story with HTML and CSS
now right you we have been saying all of
this was done in R but if you are
looking at what you have to do to make
this happen even though we are using our
code what you need to do is to wrap the
words that you want to highlight into
these span Texs and inside of these span
Texs you have to set the color to some
hex code that you want to use so really
this is HTML and CSS these span Texs
that's HTML and the style instruction
inside of it that's CSS and even though
we could get very far to accomplish our
goal with just within R we have been
great tool for that we had to Sparkle in
a little bit of HTML and CSS to make
this happen and the very nice thing is
that it isn't actually that hard to make
this work right if you can create a
scatter plot with GG plot like that then
you certainly won't have any trouble to
set like the words into span text and
then throw in a couple of keywords and
we will see that this is a recurring
theme within with the tools that we like
to
use so I have mentioned that you can add
a little bit of HTML and CSS to your
data visualizations with ggplot but it's
also true for other very popular tools
and this is what I've noticed it's true
for tables with GT it's true for reports
and slides with qual and it's true for
dashboards that you create with shiny
all of these packages or tools are gr
out of the box they can they can create
beautiful outputs and we can get very
far all from within that tool that you
use but if you want to make something
unique if you want to make something a
little bit special like having the
colors in the title instead then you
need to add a little bit of HTML and CSS
to it I like to compare this to building
houses you can create or can build a
very nice a very solid home all with an
R nothing wrong about that but if you
want to add build something very special
want to have something very fancy then
you will you are kind of forced to add a
little bit of HTML and CSS to it but
really the point that I want to make
here is that just with the data
visualization where you only had to
throw in these span Texs it isn't that
hard once you at the point that you can
already create the nice home so the
transition using the HTML and CSS isn't
that
hard to prove my point let's look at a
couple more examples here's a table that
I have created with GT once again and
it's a very amazing tool that we have at
our disposal GT can make a very nice
table here it's a solid table it shows a
couple of measurements from the penguin
data set and it even has like a little
chart in there to visualize the
distribution of the penguin weights and
even though this is an neat table it may
be a bit boring it's just plain black
and white and you may need to draw your
reader's attention to that specific
table that you have so you might want to
throw in a little bit of color in there
add like a linear gradient to make
things look fancy just to grab your
reader attention and the same story is
here happening again basically this was
all done in GT but to make this happen
you created your table in R and then
passed this to some overlay in this case
it's called op CSS where you stick in
CSS code to make the final changes that
you want and again the story here is
that the part that is highlighted is
only a couple of keywords that are
pretty hard to pretty easy to understand
I I mean I will guess that you won't
have any trouble understanding what
border top with does when you set it to
one pixel right the only thing that may
might be a little bit Troublesome is the
things that are gr out here these are
the description of where you want to
apply your Styles but the cool thing
about this is that usually you don't
have to write these things yourself you
just have to figure out where to look
and then you copy and paste the thing
and throw that in there so this is how I
made this thing I mean I just copy and
pasted the descriptions and then I set
the keywords to what I want and the
keywords are easily Googled if you want
to figure out what changes the
background in CSS you Google just that
and you see that background will do the
job same thing is true in chiny in chiny
you can just throw in a couple of
keywords to a lot of UI elements to make
your user interface look different and
once you're comfortable with using these
nice and easy keyword value pairs you
can start to use more complex stuff from
CSS like the grid alignment to like take
your UI elements that you have from
within shiny and arrange that on a grid
here that's how I created the shiny app
this little habit tracker and basically
this is how I leverage CSS here to get
the job done and finally we have quto
which I like to call a web development
gateway
drug it it it really is true it's all a
quook generates so much great output for
you out of the box and a lot of times
that's HTML and CSS and then you're
thinking okay I want to change this tiny
thing to make the theme similar to what
I want and then you're like hooked you
want to like figure out how do I do this
and this is really how you end up
learning more about HTML and CSS and
this is how I ended up there too and the
very cool thing is that quo is a great
place to learn the HTML and CSS because
it already generates all of the code for
you you just have to figure out where to
look once you know that you can copy and
paste most of the code from there and
change the values to what you want if it
says background is white copy and paste
it and set background to Blue if that's
what you need so with that you can get
very far and the thing about quto is
that for example if you create slides
like these you can do things like in
little chunks for example you could
interpret every slide as a little web
development project and do some fancy
stuff there here I definitely want to
mention that this theme isn't by me it
is great but it is uh from Emil I
borrowed that he will speak about
probably more amazing quar of themes uh
just uh after me and this saying of
every slide is a little web development
project is something I have picked up
from Garrick Aden Buie who also stressed
this point so it's it's not an new idea
but it is worth repeating that you can
like start working on very small project
to easier way into the HTML and CSS
world so this backs the question how do
we actually start with that I gave you a
couple of examples and showed you like
after the fact this is how it was done
but how do we figure out these things
and again quto is the base for us our
users or qu to users it's the best way
to start out because most of the things
are already done for us and in this case
you can use so-called scss variables to
just throw in a scss so-called scss file
into your quter document set the theme
to that file it really is just a text
file that you rename to something
something. sccss and then you have an
scss file and in there you can use uh as
I said scss variables and set them to
very specific values this is this is
really the easiest way you can style a
lot of your qu to outputs by figuring
out what the couple of keywords are that
you want to use here the first three
keywords are the primary and secondary
and thary color and I've just set them
to some hex code and by just setting
this in this scss file you can
immediately transform the output of your
quoto file basically the theme is
changed then and the same thing could be
done for the code background or the code
chunk uh background color
and so on so you really have to figure
out what is the keyword that I need and
then you set it to some value and
thankfully the quter documentation is
pretty solid on that part you can just
go to the quter website look for the zus
variables scss and S are kind of the
same thing and there you will see the
most important variables and their names
are kind of
self-explanatory and then set that to
some value that you want so that's
basically the easy easy route to easier
way into HTML and CSS with Quon and once
you go want to go wild you once you
cannot do something with the basic scss
variables to make the changes that you
want then it becomes time to look at the
actual HTML and CSS code that quarter
generates for you and on any website you
can do this you can just take your web
browser write click
anywhere uh drop down menu will appear
and then you can navigate to inspect
just imagine that there is inspect and
not the German a word for it and then
you would uh know what you have to
click I deliberately not clicked inspect
right now because honestly this part is
scary once you open it up the web
developer view will immediately show up
and you will see a bunch of stuff you
will see the HTML all the CSS and a
thousand other tools I have never use or
I don't even know what they do honestly
but really it opens so many things and
you need need someone to kind of guide
you through it but once you have that
part the strategy to like make the
changes that you want to learn HTML and
CSS is pretty straightforward inspect
all the things that you want to change
this will immediately put you to the
HTML and CSS code that generates that
output copy and paste that stuff into
your scss
file and then simply change the values
to that what you need so as I said you
kind of need someone to guide you
through it you could of course try this
at home and just uh click inspect and
see what's happening but it's always
easy to have someone show you where to
look how it works and once that is done
it's like a 10minute intro then you know
how to operate with these three steps
but then it really is as easy as I've
said copy and paste most of the things
and add the values after the fact and
that's why I decided to actually make
such an introduction because because I
cannot do this here would make too much
would take too much time so this is why
uh you will find on YouTube a quarto
themes guide for HTML and CSS snoops
that guides you through that this is
actually part two part one will um show
you more details on the first part that
I have mentioned with the scss variables
so you can start with part one check out
how far you can go with there and then
use part two to see how much you can get
done with the we developer View and with
that thank you for coming for my talk
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you
have thank you we have indeed time for
qu uh time for questions I was much
faster than I practiced so first
question have you dipped at all into
JavaScript for enhancing your
apps yeah but this is like a scary world
I I I mean I have dipped into it and it
is very very fascinating what you can do
um but I feel like the easier way to all
the things you want to change for style
HTML and CSS or
enough uh what are the limitations of
HTML and CSS in the r
context like if I can't ask questions
back I guess so I don't think there are
any limitations I mean basically all the
websites in the world that you see are
built on HTML and CSS and you can see
varieties of websites and I don't think
there's like imagination is the limit
for HTML and CSS I guess the only thing
that might be like in the r context be
specific is um for example the GG text
example it doesn't accept all style
instructions it only accepts those that
were implemented in that kind of
scenario there is truly is a limit then
you would have to figure like some heck
something out so the G so the GG text
output that works not only in HTML
output right so that output can be
that's any gig plot which you can save
into a PDF file I mean at the end it
generates a image file and the way that
you need to instruct to make the changes
is via HTML and CSS code I'm not 100%
sure what GG text does behind the scenes
with that instruction but you have to
use that language to instructed to do it
right right another question what is a
good way to share your new quarto themes
with others so I guess if you modify you
know a document maybe you want to do
that again to another document to use
the same theme or same style I mean
honestly we would share it I personally
would share it like I would share all
things via GitHub repository the slide
that I showed from Emil here that's how
I got it I knew Emil shared his themes
on cour on GitHub I just went there and
looked into this scss file and then put
that into my scss file so you just need
to share the scss files basically that's
the theme B basically and all the
resources that you want to have for
example in this very specific case there
are also images these are all images
then you also need the image file for
that of course thank you you're
[Applause]
welcome